[Applause]
[Music]
in more serious news
three mass shootings took place in
america this past weekend and they came
just one week after the shooting in
brooklyn now every time something like
this happens americans ask the same
question will congress finally introduce
a meaningful gun control bill well last
night i saw a commercial for two
lawmakers who are trying to do just that
take a look
hello i'm dan davenport and i'm carol
kerrigan and we're united states
congress people over and over again
americans are subjected to acts of gun
violence but no one in congress ever
seems to do anything about it
that's why this week we're coming
together to introduce bill h.r 321 a
bill that will require all guns in the
u.s to be imprinted with the phrase hey
be careful now
that's right if our bill is passed into
law every gun well in the nation will
have the phrase hey be careful now print
it right on it it could be on the butt
of the gun or on the scope or on the
shooty part
i don't really know the names of the
parts of a gun even though i own 30 of
them
the point is we take gun control
seriously we're doing something about it
and that thing we're willing to do is
make sure every gun is emblazoned with
the phrase hey be careful now
we know what you're thinking couldn't
you ban assault rifles instead or close
gun show loopholes or ban gun ownership
for people convicted of domestic
violence
no
but what we can do is put the phrase hey
be careful now on every gun and we can
do it in all caps so people take us
seriously when we turned on the news
last week and saw one gun related
tragedy after another we knew we had to
do something so we consulted the experts
we said what can we do to reduce gun
violence
they gave us a bunch of suggestions and
we ignored them all
and we wrote this bill instead
but this bill won't pass without your
support so if you care about america or
more importantly if you care about
seeming like you care about america
then call your congressperson today and
ask them to vote yes on h.r 321
h.r 321
because nothing stronger has any chance
of passing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you